Hi.
It's about as intimidating
as I thought it would be.
(Laughter)
And yet you’d think or I’d think
that I'd be accustomed
to more stressful situations.
You see, I work in international security
and in conflict resolution.
And today, I'm here to talk
about some of our blind spots
related to decarbonization.
Now, what does one have to do
with the other, you may ask.
Good question.
We often hear that a climate-safe future
is a necessary condition for peace.
That's true.
We also often hear that renewables
could be the energy of peace.
Less true.
To understand, I need to tell you
about the materials that we need
in order to decarbonize.
They're pretty.
And they can be deadly.
Looking into their story tells us
that confronting conflict
and building new forms
of international peace
are going to be critical foundations
to build a climate-safe future.
So let me tell you about them,
starting with where we stand now.
When we talk about a decarbonized future,
we generally have in mind the possibility
of decoupling economic growth
from greenhouse gas emissions.
That’s what we call “green growth.”
What we tend to think about less often
is that to get there
we need to recouple economic growth
with intensive mineral extraction.
To harness renewables or renewable
energy like the sun and the wind,
we obviously need to build
technologies such as solar panels,
windmills, batteries, right?
And to build those,
we need to mine huge quantities
of non-renewable materials
such as these.
Knowing that it takes mines
as big as these
to produce that much amount
of usable material.
Our ticket to green growth,
in other words,
is digging deep in the environment.
Now we know that mining
can have grave impacts
for local ecosystems and populations.
I’ve seen it myself,
and it really isn’t pretty.
But what I want to talk about today
is about how much and where
we’re going to have to dig,
and what that means for planetary
security and for geopolitics.
I'll start from there.
History tells us
that when the dominant
source of energy changes,
power relations change as well.
Countries that can transform energy
to their own advantage,
can gain the upper hand
economically and politically,
and then can put themselves
at the center of the global order.
Think of the United Kingdom
and coal, for instance,
or how oil determined the ascendance
of the US to a global superpower.
What that tells us is that the access to
and processing of energy
literally materializes into the ability
to shape geopolitical power dynamics.
And today,
we're facing the challenge of implementing
the biggest energy transition
in the history of humankind
under a ticking climate clock.
The race is on for a new
generation of power.
At the heart of which you have
all of the critical materials
that we need to decarbonize
on the one hand
and digitalize on the other.
So what's happening with them?
On the demand side we're at the beginning
of an exponential demand curve.
If you take lithium as a proxy,
a key component for [batteries],
global production already increased
by just short of 300 percent
between 2010 and 2020.
I'm going to pause here for a sec.
This is really good news.
It means that decarbonization
is in motion.
The not so good news
is that our "clean" future
is going to be more materially
intensive than before.
If you take a simple measure for it,
the International Energy Agency tells us
that with the current level of innovation,
an electric car requires six times
more mineral inputs
than a conventional car.
And this is only the start.
The World Bank tells us
that with the current projections,
global production for minerals
such as graphite and cobalt
will increase by 500 percent by 2050,
only to meet the demand
for clean energy technologies.
Now let's look on the supply side.
That's where a lot of really
interesting things are happening.
Who currently exploits
and processes minerals
and where deposits
to meet future demand are located
tell us exactly how the transition
is going to change geopolitics.
So if you look at a material
such as lithium,
countries like Chile and Australia
tend to dominate extraction
while China dominates processing.
For cobalt, the Democratic Republic
of Congo dominates extraction
while China dominates processing.
For nickel,
countries like Indonesia
and the Philippines
tend to dominate extraction,
while China, you guessed it, thank you,
dominates processing.
And for rare earths,
China dominates extraction
while China dominates processing.
I've just said China a lot, didn't I?
Well, that's because China
skillfully leveraged
its geo-economic rise to power
over the last two decades
on the back of integrating
supply chains for rare earths
from extraction to processing to export.
We tend to point fingers at China today
for not going fast enough
on its own domestic energy transition,
but the truth is that China
understood already long ago
that it would play a central role
in other countries' transitions.
And it is.
The European Union, for instance,
is 98 percent dependent
on China for rare earths.
Needless to say,
this puts China in a prime position
to redesign the global balance of power.
Now, you may argue
that this is a good thing
because the global balance of power
needs a rehaul anyway.
And you know what?
I can totally roll with that.
But -- and this applies to China,
the United States,
and any other big player --
we need to make sure
that the redesigning process
doesn't compromise
on human rights or open societies.
And that it doesn't lead
to the weaponization of supply chains
at a time of international instability,
and more importantly,
at a time of complete climate breakdown.
Unfortunately, we're already seeing
signs of this happening.
China is currently trying to gain
access to more mineral resources
through its Belt and Road Initiative.
The United States and Europe
are both thinking
of reshoring critical mining
and processing
and orienting some
of their international partnerships
to facilitate access to more
mineral resources.
Japan is exploring some of its
oceanic marine reserves
to build strategic reserves.
I'm also speaking in the shadow of a war
on the European continent.
Now at first sight,
Russia's invasion of Ukraine has nothing
to do with what I've been talking about.
But Ukraine happens to be mineral rich.
It also happens to be
one of only two countries
that had struck a partnership
with the European Union
to diversify and develop supply chains
for critical raw materials.
That partnership was specifically designed
to help the EU decarbonize
and in the process to better
integrate with Ukraine
from a political and economic perspective.
Eight months after
the partnership was struck,
the invasion took place.
Now, mineral resources may not explain
everything about the war.
But they certainly can't be ignored
in analyzing the events.
Because when it comes to the race
for critical raw materials,
what's actually happening
is that we're headed right back
into a new scramble for resources,
at the heart of which you find
all of the big players
eyeing countries with vast
mineral deposits.
And yet it's so obvious many of these
countries that are located,
for the most part, in Africa,
in Latin America, in Central Asia
and in the Indo-Pacific.
Economists will tell you
that this is a great thing,
because these countries,
or at least a lot of them,
need economic resources and many,
to accelerate their development pathway
and climate adaptation.
But.
Many of these countries also have
very real overlapping risk profiles.
The International Institute
for Sustainable Development
first produced this map back in 2018.
Can you see the green dots on the map?
They represent all
of the different materials
that we need in order to decarbonize,
their geographic location
and their deposit size.
As it so happens, a lot of the deposits
are located in countries
that rank fairly high
on corruption indices.
They are represented essentially
by the shades of brown and red on the map.
And as it so happens,
a lot of the materials are also located
in countries that are fragile,
such as Sri Lanka,
or downright conflict
affected, like Myanmar
and the Central African Republic.
That's not all.
The Notre Dame Institute
tells us, with this map,
in which you see, again,
some red and orange,
that countries that are climate vulnerable
are also the ones
that are resource endowed.
And one final thing.
You know those big ecosystems
that we need to protect and regenerate
in order to stabilize
the global climate regime?
To reboot the hydrological cycle
and to protect biodiversity?
They're also represented
in orange and red on this map.
Many of these big ecosystems
are located in the same fragile countries
that I was mentioning before.
They also happen to sit
on vast mineral deposits.
Changing or eliminating these ecosystems
through mining, through
deforestation or anything else
would undermine planetary security.
Not just international security.
Planetary security.
It's essentially like a perfect
storm in the making.
Corruption,
institutional and socioeconomic fragility,
climate disruptions
and environmental plundering,
all acting as a backdrop
to a competition to gain
access to the minerals
that we need in order to decarbonize.
All of these factors will be magnified
if we don't rein in
the scramble for resources.
All of them will reinforce one another.
And I want to make something
very clear here.
The countries at the heart
of the resource scrambling
may suffer the most direct consequences
in terms of their ability to develop,
to adapt to climate change
and to avoid violence.
But their fate is not isolated.
Their problems are not
geographically distant.
Our big blind spot here
is that we're headed towards
a decarbonization trajectory
that may end up undermining
ecological integrity
and heighten the risks
of conflict and insecurity
whose consequences
would reverberate worldwide.
I know that this is not
a particularly encouraging picture.
And that it comes on top
of layers of pictures
that are not particularly encouraging.
Our modern economies have advanced
and grown for two centuries
through the gigantic blind spot
of fossil fuel exploitation
and its unintended consequences.
The big lesson here
is that we can't afford to just shift
to a different set of energies,
technologies and materials
without paying attention
to the unintended consequences.
The stakes are too high.
They involve our future.
That we know.
But they also involve our humanity.
And they involve our nature,
by which I mean the nature
that we choose for ourselves.
Decarbonization is the way forward.
There’s not one single doubt
allowedd about this.
But the way forward also demands of us
that we start imagining our future
beyond decarbonization already.
Remember what I said at the beginning?
A climate-safe future
is a necessary condition for peace.
But we won't achieve
a climate-safe future without peace.
And to build peace,
we need to shake things up
in international politics
and in the way that we do
business and economics.
So where do we start?
I'd like to offer the scaffolding
of a plan in four different baskets.
First, science.
Science can tell us exactly where
it is safe to mine and where it isn't,
from an ecological perspective.
Where it is not safe to mine,
we need to act as though
these minerals did not exist
and establish protected areas
under which no mining
licensing can take place.
Where mining does take place,
we can integrate socioeconomic
and ecological regeneration
within business models.
Second, a global public good regime.
If decarbonization is a matter
of human survival,
then the materials that we need
in order to decarbonize
should be managed collectively
under a global public good regime.
The alternative is conflict
and planetary breakdown.
So while we figure out exactly how
to design this regime,
the countries at the heart
of the scramble for resources
should receive adequate support,
competent and coherent support
to face off the joint challenges
of geopolitical competition
and climate disruptions on the other hand.
In other words, investing
into conflict resolution,
into the fight against corruption
and into context-specific resilience,
should be top priorities
of our global energy transition.
Third,
changing the way that we do
business and economics.
We can't just switch
from one energy system to another.
I've made that pretty clear, right?
What we need instead
is to reduce our need
for energy and for materials.
And that starts with massive public
and private investments
into circular economic models
that favor recyclability
and material substitution.
Now, here's the thing.
We know that this is a necessary step,
but not a sufficient one.
So what we also need to do
is to develop ecological
assessments for supply chains
that account for greenhouse gas emissions,
but also for water, soil,
biodiversity, material
and energy footprint all at once.
Only on this all-encompassing basis
will we understand how supply
and distribution chains need to change
and therefore how globalization
needs to transform.
Fourth,
innovation.
All of this can only happen
if we start shifting our thinking
about innovation.
Innovation in our times
is about bringing back economic footprint
within planetary boundaries.
Anything else, even the coolest
of new products,
if it isn't aligned with that goal,
it's not innovation,
it's business as usual.
In our little corner of the world,
my team and I at Carnegie Europe
have been working really hard
to identify what regenerative
foreign policy looks like
and what it aims for.
There are two things that we know by now.
One is obvious, we need
to tackle fundamental issues
around economic redistribution
on a global scale.
The other thing is that we need
a geopolitical de-escalation
around decarbonisation and regeneration.
We've translated that into a concept
we've called ecological diplomacy.
And we're pushing really hard
for the European Union
to adopt this framework
within their foreign policy.
Because if there is one thing
that we've understood,
it's that ecological integrity
is the foundation
for all types of security.
Which makes it the one common denominator
that we can work
on rebuilding collectively.
And we can manage.
Truly, I believe that we can.
As long as we shed light
on our transition blind spots
and take them as our guiding companions
to identify what truly systemic,
truly peaceful
and truly safe solution pathways look like
for the age of climate-disrupted futures.
Thank you so much.
(Applause)